hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream 205 being the number
um so clearly not prime uh I'm Dr Brett
Weinstein you are Dr Heather hying we
have just returned from uh a trip to the
Bahamas and uh we are going to talk
about some things that we saw and uh
what it might imply about the state of
the world or not and um anyway more
things like that yep that's that's where
we're going to spend our time today
maybe we'll talk about woolly dogs too
woolly dogs woolly dogs all right and
maybe uh we will um take a brief look at
the space weather okay all right um so
uh we will do a Q&A our final Q&A
actually no not our final Q&A of the
year we will do a Q&A um after today's
live stream in the New Year we're going
to reduce these to once a month month
but we will continue to do as well our
private q&as on locals which we do on
the last Sunday of the month uh which
this month falls on December 31st New
Year's Eve so uh join us on locals this
New Year's Eve uh at 11:00 a.m. for
2hour private Q&A we have a lot of fun
with those uh they're small enough that
we actually look at the chat and can
engage with the chat um other things
that you can find on locals are for
instance our watch party right now that
happens uh while we are live streaming
both evolutionary lens and the q&as that
we do and and um there's early release
of guest episodes there uh um amas with
uh with Brett Zach and I did one once
access to Discord lots more yeah if you
were going to be a stickler over details
and you wanted to Hash it out that'd be
a place and then we could also stickle
back yeah we could totally stick totally
stickle back and um since I think since
we saw you last or since you saw us last
uh the guest episode with um the World
War II veteran whom you met Martin agian
the last probably the last B7 pilot
alive at least who flew during World War
II people love this episode I think I
was hoping that they would be interested
to hear a man who has seen as much of
history as Martin agian has he's 100
years old 100 years old he says he's
looking to eek out another five he'll be
satisfied with that anyway very
fascinating fella and he was right here
in the studio he was right here um I
mean it wasn't all that easy explaining
to him what a podcast is but nonetheless
once he kind of got the gist um he was
he was ready to go that's awesome okay
so check that out and if you'd been on
locals you would have gotten that a day
earlier um and um yeah we're going to
move the rest of the stuff that we're
going to tell you about till the end
except for our sponsors as always we
have uh three fantastic sponsors to
start uh the episode today um that's the
only place you'll have ads um from us
during the show and if we are speaking
ads then you know that we actually vouch
for the products and you're going to
start wow there you go somehow after 205
episodes I did not see that coming our
first sponsor this week is mind Bloom
which offers atome ketamine therapy a
new tool to improve your mental health
if you are struggling with anxiety or
depression You Are Not Alone millions of
Americans are searching for ways to feel
better but feel like searching for ways
to feel better but feel like they've
exhausted every option and don't know
where to turn if that sounds like you
then guided ketamine therapy from mind
Bloom could be a GameChanger mind Bloom
can help you feel better faster mind
Bloom is the leader in ketamine therapy
having helped tens of thousands of
people overcome their anxiety and
depression mind blooms expert clinicians
and guides can help you feel better in
days not weeks and you can complete
treatment entirely from the comfort of
your home in a study of over a thousand
mind- Bloom clients 89% reported
Improvement in their anxiety and
depression after only four sessions now
mind Bloom has new programs that go
beyond depression and anxiety to help
you overcome challenges in everyday life
I wonder if they have anything for
spelling um reading live anyway we'll
find out right now mind Bloom is
offering our listeners $100 off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mind bloom.com
Darkhorse and use the promo code
Darkhorse break free from your anxiety
and depression and feel better faster
with mind Bloom that's m m i n d
bom.com
Darkhorse and use the promo code
Darkhorse yeah you're one of those rare
creatures who I'm guessing never had any
anxiety about public speaking but public
reading that's a totally different
different thing well I I hate to say
this but I think everybody has anxiety
about public speaking until you do it a
zillion times and my I still I mean I my
I don't have anxiety about standing in
front of a crowd and speaking but
definitely certain topics uh well sure I
mean you you to take things seriously
and uh and know that you know it's a
live fire exercise things could go wrong
in all of this but um to the degree that
for some some people claim that public
speaking is their number one fear you
know the thing that they fear absolutely
the most um and I I think and you know
maybe I'm just misreading what you what
you just said but that you you actually
uh regard public reading as more of a
more of an issue than public speaking
very difficult tough extemporaneously
yep um my number one fear is probably
effective altruists but uh really yes
yeah but Mo
eels uh you know if they've got good
mores I don't think they have any beef
with me so yeah see beefs
see all right this is gone strange but
we're going to get back end of the year
what are you going to do yeah exactly
yep our second sponsor this week is MD
hearing we have have friends and family
who have hearing loss there's a good
chance that you do too well we don't
have need for hearing aids ourselves we
have a good friend who does we asked her
to assess MD hearings newest product
carefully and honestly honestly her
testimonial is at the end of this ad
they've got an even newer one coming out
soon we're going to hear a new
testimonial I believe um next time but
here we are with the uh second
testimonial second product that's been
assessed by our friend positively MD
hearing makes high quality simple and
effective hearing aids for a tiny
fraction of what what most hearing aids
cost helping bring audio Clarity and
capacity to people who might not
otherwise be able to afford it MD
hearing was founded by an ENT surgeon
who made it his mission to develop a
quality hearing aid that anyone could
afford he keeps the price Low by
removing several rarely needed
components MD hearings Neo model costs
over 90% less than Clinic hearing aids
and the Neo is MD hearing's smallest
hearing aid ever it fits inside your ear
and no one will know it's there MD
hearings products also have rechargeable
batteries that last up to 30 hours and
their volt plus model is water resistant
and up to three ft of water you don't
need a prescription which also means
there's no middleman here is the newest
testimonial from our friend who a
substantial hearing loss and who relies
on hearing aids we asked her to try this
product and this is what she said I
tested the Neo the Neo I think you say
it Neo yeah yeah I tested the Neo she
writes MD hearings new in thee Canal
hearing aids I was a bit skeptical since
I've never liked the in thee Canal
models preferring the stability of
overthe sets they were surprisingly
comfortable and stable staying put
without coming loose even when I wore
them to exercise I tried the Neo in
several situations from Discord voice
chat to an in-person conversation in a
room with a white noise generator and
they passed every test it is true that
they don't have the individual audiogram
programming and smartphone integration
of my usual hearing aids but they have
everything else for less than 5% of the
price they provide an absolutely
stunning level of quality for pennies on
the dollar if you want MD hearing
smallest hearing a ever go to MD
hearing.com and use promo code Darkhorse
to get their new $297 when you buy a
pair offer head to MD hearing.com and
use promo code dark hor to get their
brand new 297 when you buy a pair offer
it's a fabulous deal for a fabulous
product you know when it comes to
hearing aids the only person between
them the middleman should be you or
middle woman I don't know but if you
think about never
mind well it sounds like MD hearing is
uh thinking along the same lines yes
they've gotten rid of the middleman
entirely leaving the position open for
you to inhabit it between the hearing
aids and to hear better as a result I
would hope m Sundays our final sponsor
this week Mattie's alltime favorite she
is asleep behind us out of view of the
camera unfortunately just as HED glad to
have us home that dog is Sunday's is one
of our favorites too not just hers
because when you make your dog this
happy while giving her amazing food that
is good for her what's not to be
thrilled about Sundays makes dry dog
food but it's not your usual dry dog
food this is no standard issue burnt
kibble the standard high-end burnt
kibble that we were feeding Maddie
pleases her well enough she's a lab labs
will basically eat anything but it turns
out that does discriminate she loves the
food that Sundays makes seriously loves
it if we run out of Sundays and give her
her previous high and kibble instead she
is clearly disappointed we should be
giving her Sundays she knows it and we
know it not only is Sunday's mat
Sunday's madd's favorite food it's also
far better for her than the standard
burnt kibble that comprises most dried
dog food it's the only human grade air
dried dog food Brett checked it's human
grade air drying combines the best of
cooked and raw approaches like raw air
drying preserves nutrients and taste
better than high heat methods better
than raw though Sunday's unique air
drying process includes a kill step
which kills pathogens so unlike
freeze-dried raw or frozen raw Doug
Foods there is no food safety or
handling risk with Sundays and Sundays
has no artificial binders synthetic
additives or other garbage all of
Sunday's ingredients are easy to
pronounce and healthy for dogs to eat
Sundays is an amazing way to feed your
dog there's no fridge no prep no cleanup
no wet dog food smells it's a total
pleasure for the human interacting with
it which is a bonus in a blind taste
test Sunday's outperformed leading
competitors 40 to Z and her own little
anecdote Maddie our Labrador supports
that result she bounces and Spins and
leaps in anticipation for a bowl of
Sundays way more than for her previous
food do you want to make your dog happy
with her diet and keep her healthy try
Sundays we've got a special deal for our
listeners receive 35% off your first
order go to Sundays 4dogs Darkhorse or
use code Darkhorse checkout that's s n
dys f r
dogs.com Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about you're feeding your dog
or your
husband wow I see what's coming no I I
never fed it to you no you didn't I did
it well it was and you know how to cook
so this was a choice this was a I I felt
that our ability to uh to have a proper
testimonial for the dog food was
important so you know
took English no she she indicates but
she does not nothing quotable nothing
quotable nothing quotable yeah um so
let's start actually by talking a little
bit about the space weather phenomenon
that delayed our trip by a day okay um
we had been planning to go on this uh
adventure to return to the Bahamas as
we've done for the last uh couple years
and something emerged in the news that
gave us pause and it wasn't widely
reported but if you were paying
attention to the right channels you saw
it and what it was was some activity on
the Sun that kicked loose two solar
storms there was an mclass and an xass
those are the two highest categories and
then with within each of them there's a
numeric categorization these were not
absolutely gigantic this was a a
moderate and a pretty big but what it
did was caused us
to um think twice about getting on an
airplane as a result of the fact that
these solar storms these are basically
flares that in some cases uh throw
um what's called a coronal mass ejection
uh off the Sun and they do this in
effectively random directions and if
they head towards the Earth they can
have very serious effects the most
important historical example of this is
something called the Carrington event of
1859 I don't know why everything
happened in 1859 it's weird it's funny
yeah so many things happened in 1859
pastor's experiment demonstrating uh
that the life comes from life and does
not spontaneously regenerate Darwin's
Origin of Species the pig War the pig
War the pig War Began here in the San
wans um anyway relatively insignificant
moment you know at the at the global
level but but nonetheless um and then
there's this Carrington event and what
the Carrington event was Carrington
event was named after an amateur
astronomer I believe who noticed um the
correlation between a extraordinary
solar event and A disruption of what
would at the time have been a very uh
primitive electronic infrastructure
mostly T what do you call them yeah
telegraphs um these were basically wires
that connected distant locations where
somebody who uh typed in the morse code
was able to send messages uh over these
long distances and um not only were
these systems disrupted but the
uh coronal mass ejection induced a
current so that even disconnected
messages were still sendable so in
addition to Telegraph operators getting
shocked um they had these weird
phenomena where they could send messages
even though the system was off um anyway
it was um a pretty large storm and it
had significant effects on the very
small electric infrastructure of the
earth since 1859 the electronic
infrastructure of the Earth has grown
spectacularly obviously if you think
about all of the things that are uh
electronic in nature um our whole
civilization depends on it at many many
different levels and so anyway the
thought that something had happened on
the sun because we now have good uh
detectors we knew something about the
nature of it uh and just so that people
are aware of what these um what these
things
are you have an immediate burst of what
I think are X-rays that uh happen and
those x-rays reach the Earth just like
sunlight in a matter of minutes
something like8 minutes later um they
reached the Earth and there was in fact
a communication disruption as a result
of the uh the solar storm um two days
before we two or three days before we
left um so that suggested uh that this
was a significant event um and the
question was was the coronal mass
ejection going to hit the earth um
sufficiently directly to disrupt
Communications down here on Earth
potentially knock out uh components of
various grids and does that put you in
Jeopardy if you happen to be in
mid-flight at the time um so mid-flight
on a plane that is reliant on
electronics right reliant on electronics
exactly um and you know reliant on
things uh yeah reliant on electronics
both its own electronics and um
Electronics on the ground right you know
this can have effects on satellites it
can there are all kinds of ways in which
it can be disruptive so anyway we
delayed and it became clear over the
course of the couple of days it or
several days it would have taken for the
uh the particles to reach the Earth that
the although the um the storm itself was
not directed at Earth that it would that
we would effectively get a glancing blow
and it would not be serious so um the
reason I rais this is because I'm still
stunned by the fact that our grid is not
hardened to these disruptions there is a
risk uh something like a one and8 risk
every decade of a major grid disruption
that is to say something that would
destroy Transformers on which the grid
is dependent and
the shocking fact is these aren't parts
that we have in Surplus they're not
parts that you can easily order if your
Transformers are destroyed it's
something like a year um before you can
get one replaced and if you had 20 or 30
of them destroyed at a time there's no
telling what that would do so the danger
of solar storms is substantial the cost
of fixing them seems large but it isn't
apparently we could immunize all of our
Transformers um in North America from
this for something like what it would
cost to buy a stealth bomber right which
is a big cost it's many billions but
it's a small enough amount of money that
nobody would notice it if we decided to
budget that and take care of this issue
um in a permanent way and yet we don't
somehow the the the idea is so remote to
most people the idea that the sun is
going to fling something off that's
going to disrupt things on earth
sufficiently that it might do so so that
you know that we would have effects for
you know Years or or more
um it it's nobody's top priority and so
even though many people are aware of
this um it doesn't get dealt with it's
also difficult um at the human level for
many people to take in the idea of this
is uh statistically probable at this
level uh it is uh almost certain to
happen at some point um but we can't
give you specificity as to when we can't
give you spe and and it's you know and
it yes it's expensive to solve at you
know the level of any human U but we're
not talking about a human solving it
we're talking about economy solving it
we're talking about governments solving
it and so you know these car these
so-called Carrington events named after
um the first one in 1859 is something I
just looked it up you know we mentioned
them in our book uh this is something um
that uh you and particular uh have been
thinking about for a very long time and
um it is precisely the sort of thing
that humans that all humans are capable
of but you need to put a little bit of
effort in to considering um what is the
value in protecting against a thing that
is absolutely going to happen but we
can't tell you when yeah uh
it you know it results in all kinds of
what's called discounting right the
places that you can put your effort
where you can increase your profit and
reduce your risk in a in a way that's
much more predictable um causes people
to default to this and so I think
everybody who is aware of the real
Hazard is also aware of the Paradox of
us not doing anything about it um but
it's it's very clearly the result of
some kind of cognitive defect it's not
like anybody's making a profit from our
vulnerability here as far as I'm aware
it's hard to imagine how they would yeah
um so anyway Zack would you show the uh
this is just something for people to uh
look at if they want
um to think more deeply about this is a
unheard asked me to write uh on this
topic and so I wrote when was this I
dayare 2021 I think it was summer 2021
we go um but so I just scroll up again
so for people who are only listening
it's called how the Sun could wipe us
out a burst of plasma with set in motion
and devastating Cascade of failures yep
and you know anyway I just basically
wrote a a narrative uh in which the very
predictable uh coronal mass ejection
eventually hits Earth squarely enough to
create a serious event but not in
Carrington's time in our time with so
much being dependent on the electrical
grid and then the cascading uh events
that compound the problem
um and anyway I was a little even though
this is something I've been focused on
for a very long time I was a little
surprised at how easy it was to write
about how the problem snowballs from one
that is fundamentally about electrical
power to something that is fundamentally
about humans in dire
circumstances um so anyway check it out
if you're interested in
um uh space weather and the possible
hazards that come from it but also I
would advise people to start thinking
about um how well prepared they are for
things like a major disruption of the
grid where it doesn't just simply come
back up hours later right that's our
typical experience of grid failures is
yeah I guess we haven't said that like I
mean you you alluded to it with you know
you could take out these Transformers
that we don't just have a bunch of these
parts on hand the world doesn't have
these parts on hand uh so in the event
of a very large coronal mass ejection
the likes of a Carrington event uh it
could be months into years um before
return um of the GR if possible at all
yes and the question is what unfolds in
the absence of an electrical grid that
stretches into at least many months and
presumably years um what exactly does
happen right what is the plan
to keep stuff normal uh well and I mean
there's no normal as everyone listening
and watching to this knows because um
you lose all CS right you lose all
communication and suddenly the world has
become a simultaneously an
extraordinarily local place and also one
um that depending on where you are
people are either fleeing from or coming
to because it seems like the place that
uh that might be a place that you could
survive long term yep so all right uh
anyway on that bright note shall we um
shall we talk about our trip to the
Bahamas and what it caused us to think
about um yeah it's not all that bright
though this is the particular thing you
want to focus on yeah well let just say
we have we have some interesting puzzles
but um so Zack do you want to show I I
took an odd picture from the plane uh
leaving Florida and into the Bahamas
it's actually the shadow of our plane on
a cloud it's not a very good picture but
it did there was a phenomenon here that
maybe one of our viewers will be able to
help us figure out but what it was was
what appeared to be something like a
rainbow circular
surrounding the um the shadow of the
plane on the clouds and it's stuck in
that configuration long enough that I'm
sure it was not an accident that you
know the sun uh was directly behind us
from the point of view of that spot
which created this uh this um prism
effect so it doesn't have the brightness
um that I that I'm used to and so I
can't I can't be totally sure but I
think that uh whereas a standard rainbow
is Roi Biv y right uh in which the I the
Indigo was is mostly there just to make
it pronounceable uh because blue and
indigo what exactly is the difference um
but if if they're all there I believe in
this uh sort of circular Aura around the
plane shadow it's vibir Roy it looks it
looks uh outer to Inner uh violet indigo
blue green red orange yellow so that's
interesting now I do do wonder where in
which so it's not um so the the red
orange yellow has reversed um as it's
there's like there's a a inversion an
inversion thank you an inversion well
okay so we talked about uh rainbows and
somebody fog bows somebody suggested
fogbow was the term we should have been
using but anyway not for this but
suffice it to say I don't think it much
matters you've got water vapor
presumably breaking light apart in into
uh a discernable
Spectrum in the last discussion we had
of this I was talking about the fact
that from my vehicle the rainbow was
clearly very close to the vehicle
because although it appeared to be many
miles away if I looked against the
mountains if I looked down it was
actually in front from my perspective of
the railing of the road right so that
you can like see it in the um Splash out
of the tires of the cars in front of you
under certain conditions precisely and
it was the same Arc as the one on the
mountain so it was my mind putting it
far away uh if I looked up but it was
really physically the the water that was
breaking apart the light was clearly
close to my eye the whole way around
that was my inference from the last time
now in this
case I can't say for sure there's
obviously water vapor between us in the
cloud but my sense is something about
this has to do with the water in that
Cloud itself MH um and I guess I think
that for a couple of different reasons
one I don't somebody will correct me if
I'm wrong but I don't think that um
humidity can create a rainbow fogbow
prism effect because that's truly water
dissolved in the atmosphere whereas rain
is droplets of liquid water so as is fog
fog is suspended water because okay yeah
it's particles it's part particles not
in the um I guess I don't know that
humidity isn't as well yeah humidity is
really water dissolved in the air and
fog is water out of solution but small
enough uh particles that it's not um
actively falling again I'm going to get
corrected like 16 different ways on this
the physicist are coming yeah right
physicist are coming the physicist are
coming yeah exactly but anyway I'd love
to know what this phenomenon was and why
it happens I'd also be curious why my
color Acuity is not nearly good enough
to say what order the colors are there
you know it's interesting you show it to
me on your phone and at first it's like
that's kind of subtle but I think I see
what I'm seeing and the screen that
we're looking at on right now it almost
it's a different it it
actually as I'm looking at it right now
that looks like Roi Biv outer to Inner
um so I don't know now I've got two
different two different screens of the
same shot in which the colors look
different so I kind of give up since I
didn't see it in real time I don't know
what I would have seen yep all right
well anyway I'm I'm very curious as to
what comes back I also know because
Double Rainbows are a thing um that
there is a repeating sequence that
basically we don't see the triple
rainbow but presumably whatever
phenomenon it is uh keeps going and so
that raises the question as you take
something that has a large Arc and you
shrink it down or maybe this doesn't
even have a large Arc because if you
compare it to the one that I saw driving
that was feet from me this one if this
really was the cloud was really the one
at a great distance and you know so
anyway there's a question about the rate
the actual radius of the um the circle
that is described by the water particles
that are breaking apart the light um and
you know it's possible in fact it's
certain if that really is a uh prism at
the distance of that cloud that tiny
little uh circular rainbow was many
times the size of the one that I was
seeing
driving right which I don't know maybe I
I don't know again I didn't see this at
the time so I don't know how far how far
up we were and how far down those clouds
were relative to where we were so
thousands of
feet and often when you're looking at
rainbows you're um you know miles away
right but in the case of the one I saw
when driving I know that it was feet
from me because it was this side of the
rail but anyway so that is neither here
nor there with respect to the central
issue that we were planning to discuss
here um
so we got to the Bahamas the Bahamas is
a uh set of islands in the Caribbean um
the islands are can be very different
from each other there are some major
islands uh that have substantial
population centers on them um where we
spent the bulk of our time was in the
Exumas which are a set of I guess
Barrier Islands uh at the far
Northeastern edge of the
Bahamas um
but in any case these are very
um desolate pieces of land they are very
Rocky there are a small number of
species
of um plants that live on them point of
order um yes they are they the Exumas
run Northwest to Southeast and so you
know the larger islands are sort of west
west of the exus but the actual bank of
the Exuma
it runs from um I I think uh if if I've
got the naming right um Mark both the
North and the southern edge of the
Bahamas and the eastern most got it all
right do you want to show that map sure
and this is just a map that I pulled up
um um y apparently not all right in any
case um when Zach finds himself back at
the podcast desk uh it happens that I
took a video of something else that
reveals the sort of low-lying
uh desolate islands of the Exumas um
that you want to show the shark image um
uh the one
underwater video video yeah that's what
I mean um so anyway what we're going to
see here is there's
a uh I think that's not the one yeah
that is certainly a shark um you see
that Island there that is what the
Exumas look like and then here is a
nurse shark that um was curious about us
and uh swimming into the boat if you
give her a second she will um oh jeez
the camera oh there it
is um so anyway these guys are doel and
um and calm and basically harmless you
have to really work to get attacked by a
Nur sharp yes they uh it is certain that
they can smell fear and they don't care
about it so um anyway there's no need to
be be afraid of them which causes them
not to be able to smell your fear
because you don't have any but that is
neither here nor there um so you saw
that Island there it's a low-lying
island it's got some palms and a few
other uh very low it's got a very low
canopy like maybe 6 or 8 ft uh high and
then it's surrounded by these uh in this
part of the Bahamas it's basically a
shelf and this shelf presumably emerges
from the water during ice ages it's
shallow enough um that it's uh you know
yeah I think I think we talked about it
the first time we were there a year and
a half ago or so um and I haven't
reminded myself but it's something like
uh for many hundreds of square miles uh
there's nothing deeper than 20 feet on
average and in general you're in like 8T
of water yeah something like 8T of water
obviously the tide changes that but um
but being closer to the Equator than um
most people listening to this probably
are uh the Bahamas has um and this isn't
there are other things that affect um
tide scale but um really big tides that
you may be used to if for instance
you're in Southeast Alaska or Pacific
Northwest um in general all else being
equal which it's not um the larger Tides
tend to be closer to the poles and so
you only have like a two um a two foot
difference between high and low tide
down there on the other hand um it's so
flat that you do get a lot of a lot more
land showing up in fact there was
a lagoon U that I was hanging out on uh
a little island um that was
unpopulated um I'd have um um I don't
know if we have just the the one of just
the water sure um yeah yeah right um so
at low tide you have this water flowing
through the sand flat and um at very low
tide the whole middle of this Lagoon is
above land enough that people come and
one day I saw people playing botchy
there and the next day there were like
five guys playing football um and this
doesn't this isn't the part that becomes
a fully above water sandbank but um this
is sort of the view of um of of just how
shallow it is and therefore even with
just a twoof foot difference in high and
low tide uh you can get vast differences
in what's traversable by um you know
even by like paddle board as I was on or
or by real
booat um and so you can see from those
images that there that the sand is
mostly uh empty of obvious life um it is
punctuated especially around these
islands of which there are islands of
every size from you know a few square
meters to uh many square kilometers um
could you show the uh the video of the
uh fish on the Coral
Head um
so as we discussed last time um the
snorkeling uh not not this one you can
show this one while we're at it this is
inside of a cave this is a large number
of fish that were schooling inside of
the Cave the Cave actually is a famous
cave apparently it's uh where some
important scene in the movie Thunderball
if you keep watching you'll see the cave
here's the cave
Thunderball
of it so this is called Thunderball gr
Thunderball grot but okay now if you
show the other uh okay so this is what
the snorkeling is like and it's
very devoid of most life in the Big
Sandy spots and then every so often
you've run into a coral head that's full
of uh fish grasses and parrot fish and
various other kinds
of the Caribbean brief fish yep and so
anyway
that kind of gets us into the topic that
we're going to talk about here so the
fact that in space we see a a conch um
we saw conks in numbers like we had not
seen in the previous trip in in these
vast Sandy areas um between the coral
heads tons of clothes and um something
else I think we may have talked about
before that I read about naal selections
um the the land of the exustus and the
sand is mostly um made of parrot fish
and what parrot fish eat is they scrape
with their beaks they scrape uh dead
coral and so it's mostly uh calcium
carbonate I think serves um and that's
what makes the incredibly fine sand um
which then over time the crits which is
maybe the wrong word but into into land
mass yep so okay so you've got Patches
of life Interrupted uh interrupting
large expanses in which there's very
little um now
many years ago when I wrote my
dissertation my dissertation was on
biological trade-offs and the way
Evolution uh occurs in and around
various uh various such structures and
one thing I realized in doing that work
was that for whatever reason time and
space often mirror each other such that
if you see a pattern in time you can
often find the same pattern in space it
will have a different name most of the
time uh and vice versa if you see a
pattern in space you can often find an
analog in time and so anyway you've seen
the patchy distribution of creatures
here underwater but what we noticed this
time was that there was a dir of
birds we did see a few but literally for
days on end we saw Zero gulls for
example which was very surprising in
fact the gulls were so common in the
last uh couple of visits that we even
talked about them here on the podcast in
fact the first time we saw them I had
spent some time photographing them and I
misdiagnosed them the goals the common
ones are laughing goals and
um I had thought they might be turns um
so anyway here's some laughing goals uh
that I had taken photos of on a previous
trip in April of this year and then I
don't think this is a go but you w it no
show that later that's not a goal um so
the point is we were in many of the same
places this trip as we had been on the
previous two trips and in the previous
two trips we had seen so many of these
goals they were so
ubiquitous that you would have would
never have occurred to us to take any
sort of measurements of how common they
were because you know it would have been
pointless you would have gotten huge
numbers and any fluctuation in those
huge numbers you know who's to say if it
would have even meant anything but what
what we were not expecting was the
number to go to zero and you know as
biologists looking at this creature
various things occurred to us would be
not uh not very common for a gull to be
so highly migratory that during a
perfectly habitable season like this
they would be absent from a landscape
like this but obviously one explanation
for the number to be zero would be that
they migrated somewhere else that would
be uh not very disturbing um on the
other hand for the number to drop to
zero without them migrating um raises
all kinds of questions what is going on
did something happen locally that can
happen uh in fact um here in the San
Juans there was an outbreak of a virus
that took out 90% of the deer on two of
the major islands just a few years ago
um so that was a virus from deer on the
East Coast that somehow found its way
here wiped out most of the deer and the
deer are back in incredible numbers um
so you know you could have something
local like that or it could be something
more Global but just I mean just take a
step back for a moment for those of you
who live anywhere with gulls you know
how prevalent they are they're like the
the background bird that you uh Can't
Ignore entirely because they're pretty
big bodied and they make a mess when
they feel like making a mess and they're
noisy they're
noisy and there are certainly places
where there are no GS um but there are a
lot of GS a lot of places basically
along all coastlines at least in the new
world and I I'm not sure they're
everywhere in the old world because I
haven't been anywhere I mean I haven't
been everywhere in the Old World um but
also fairly far inland in a lot of
places in the in the new world as well
and it's not just the Laughing GS that
we were seeing in the Bahamas before we
were also seeing other kinds of GS the
just the the standard gulls and gulls is
kind of a mess uh phenetically um there
are there are people who will say you're
looking at eight species when someone
else says it's all just one it's
subspecies like it's it's it's hard to
tell so sort of the species swarm um but
um put that aside like laugh and G is
clearly a different kind of kind of
looking Gull but all those other gulls
those sort of heftier bigger bodied
gulls um were also completely absent
this year completely absent in fact I
think there were days in which we didn't
see a single bird of any kind um
now um if You' show the range map I did
a little looking just to make sure that
we weren't looking at a migratory
phenomenon um and here is the range map
for laughing gulls and the Bahamas is
there uh to the east of Florida it's
that big strange blob that almost looks
like a manatee uh in the water where
it's not um it doesn't look like it's
ringing an island precisely because the
Bahamas are you know so many individual
low Ling Islands yep and I'm sorry I
didn't capture the legend here but the
color that the entire Bahamas is here is
year round residents so that go oh so
the lighter color is just migrants yeah
okay migratory Roots migrat M Yeah so
basically migration does actually happen
in laughing gulls and what it says is
that some of the northern populations
migrate south and so this is not a
northern population at all it's Central
to their range and uh being so much
Coastline uh in the Bahamas these are
permanent residents so the fact that we
weren't seeing them is indeed odd yep um
and then so I you going but also and you
already mentioned this to see so many
more conch that the number of these
these conk in the water in these Sandy
flats that otherwise just have of uh
seagrass um was surprising in the other
direction and it it wasn't from zero to
Lots you know neither end was zero in
that case so it's not as remarkable but
it was a clear enough change that both
of us commented on it maybe first thing
after coming up from snorkling at one
point like how many of those there are
yeah every time I put on my mask I
encountered way more of them than I had
seen in any previous instance now in
that case I don't know what it means it
could be you know in in
uh in many circles people who study
jellyfish right there's a recognition
that jellyfish are in some ways taking
over ecosystems that they you know as
other creatures die out the jellyfish
are winning or at least some of them are
um and it could be as a matter of fact
it's pretty likely that the if there
were major die offs of other things that
the Conch would be profiting at a high
level they would temporarily have a
whole bunch to eat potentially because I
don't actually know what they eat um I
don't know why to expect that in
particular well I um I'm just yeah I
guess I don't know either I think they
eat as a certain amount of um seagrass
but I think they also scavenge anyway we
should find that out um but uh it's
possible that the Conch are highly
seasonal also because the Conch are
widely eaten by people it's possible
that there are um effects where people
are depleting them in some places and
you could get used to a certain density
and then you go somewhere else where
nobody is uh catching them and it seems
like something has boosted the numbers
yeah I mean I guess I would have
expected that um given that they're on
the menus down there uh and given that
you know rasses and parrot fish and
colorful little reef fish are not and
indeed they are part of what draw
tourists there in the first place which
is the major economic force in the
Bahamas uh that if you were seeing
things move in One Direction that you
would see conch being depleted and the
reef fish um being protected and
therefore doing better and I feel like
we're seeing the opposite well but um
this is this is to my point there's no
way the number of conch is so large that
there's no way
um that people could be depleting them
over all of these vast uh unutilized
stretches that you might find them
depleted in certain places where they're
being heavily uh heavily harvested um
but actually may maybe if you would look
up and find out what they do eat that
would be um
useful um but while Heather's looking
that up um the question on the gulls
was pretty profound and I would say it
mirrors an experience that you and I
have had many many times where some
place that we have
gone uh and become accustomed to the
distribution of creatures has radically
changed in a very short period and it is
virtually all always in the direction of
the loss of um species that were once
common in fact we've discussed here
previously the loss of Cayman from the
place in the Amazon where we've spent a
great deal of time that they were uh
when we first started visiting there
um any nighttime Adventure on the water
would result in you seeing many Cayman
you spot them because their eyes shine
back in your headlamp and the last time
we were there I don't think we saw a one
um so that kind of depletion is um is a
familiar phenomenon what'd you find uh
that's not a an assignment you can give
me on the Fly because I don't know what
species of we're looking at down
there I quickly discovered there's lots
and lots of species um in many different
families um I'm not even sure it's
monoptic group um they are famously
referred to as uh highly predatory but
some authors seem to be disagreeing with
that so that's what I found in like 15
seconds so I'm not going to it all right
I'm not going to make a claim we'll put
it aside um we have seen many cases of
common things uh becoming so scarce that
they were not seen um in a very short
period um we've had that experience many
times and so the question here is what
to think about this now obviously what
you would want to know is somebody would
have to have had
um some kind of data you know obviously
that range map is the result of people
having uh done some kind of uh
accounting of uh individual numbers in
this species so that they know exactly
where they are and aren't um but the you
know the way that
um the way that bird populations in
particular get assessed uh is as I I
think you know but is often um by sort
of very briefly if it all trained uh lay
people sort of lay birders maybe birders
are always lay birders I don't know
there aren't any professional birders we
call those ornithologists so they're
different um who um you know their work
is sort of spot checked but um basically
if you know something and you see
something you see a species outside of
the range that you expect to see it um
there's numbers to call um but there are
also days in fact I think the the
Christmas bird count happens in a lot of
places in North America it's like
everyone's a lot of people are going to
go out and um you know pen and pen and
notebook in hand and um keep track of
everything you see but that of course
requires that the identification is
accurate and um that people have U gone
to exactly the place that they say they
have and you know they may be wrong or
they may have I I don't know why you
would lie about that but there's just a
lot of opportunity for human error so um
those range maps are not uh inherently
put together together under the most
careful scientific conditions and C it's
not I was going to it's certainly it's
not experimental at all but careful
observational conditions don't always
apply you would hope you would hope that
those range Maps would be um
conservative because you're always going
to have misidentifications that are
going to extend AR range wildly um but
repeated observations ought to ought to
draw those lines pretty carefully um but
anyway so we've got now several things
that we've discussed as possible
explanations you could have some sort of
a seasonal something or other um this
was in fact the first visit at this time
of year we've been three times in
February the first time in April earlier
this year and now in December so um not
wildly different in terms of you know
both all three of these times have been
after Hurricane Season uh is supposedly
over although we were we were there at
the tail end of a weather system that
some people were saying should have been
a named storm um did not have a name but
uh was a was a was a tropical storm that
maybe should have had a name um so all
of all of those visits within the same
season but at different spots in it so
actually okay I think we've got we've
got four possibilities on the table so
far um you've got uh some sort of
programmed seasonable seasonal migration
this does not seem to be the result of
that um you've got something like a
pathogen that wipes out the majority of
a population but it bounces back because
it doesn't go to zero and the habitat
remains hospitable as it happened with
the deer here and like has been proposed
for although we doubt this explanation
for the sea stars in the Pacific or in
the entire uh Pacific Rim really um but
um very visible in the Pacific Northwest
where there had been they were
ubiquitous in Marinas and in Rocky
beaches and they just disappeared about
a little less than 10 years ago yeah uh
disappeared almost almost completely
it's a shocking shocking level of
decrease um you've also got the
possibility that you had um a Lo a
patchy local
phenomenon um in which you just happened
to be in a place where the number was
Zero but the actual population size
hadn't changed that seems very unlikely
in this case especially since we were in
many of the same places that we'd seen
these animals before and they should be
profiting pretty much anywhere that has
Coastline right the things that they eat
they're they're opportunists and those
things should be accumulating everywhere
and then the fourth
possibility is a a massive meaningful
decline in an extremely short period of
time in this case and I guess that's the
that's the thing that's so
worrying um what what was number what
did you have you so you got Migra
migration and um it's it's actually
possible with regard to these goals
although it's not consistent with the
range map that you show
that because we are at the very
beginning of uh the season where the
weather is more safe to travel by air
and we were in fact supposedly outside
of that window but there was a big
tropical storm that was happening as we
arrived that this that that could have
been something if these birds are
migratory in this place which they're
not supposed to be y pathogen and then
your final one a massive meaningful
decline was number three on that list um
it's hard for me to keep track of the
numbers I think it was a local
patchiness that resulted in us having
effectively a sampling error issue which
seems very unlikely on the other hand
yeah but I mean we were literally in the
same place literally in the same place
but two of these times show that uh um
Thunderball uh Cave grot
yep um the very abundant fish I know so
the reason that I want to show this is
because these animals were extremely
dense in in this highly
unusual cave there are caves around but
the basic point is if you were trying to
figure out how many of that fish are in
the
Bahamas you would want to count all of
the ones that are disproportionately
concentrated somewhere and so if you
found them absent and you know this is
in fact not the most unlikely thing here
because the storm that kept us out could
have driven the bird somewhere that so
we we stayed away because of a solar
storm but there was a
separate maybe totally separate maybe
not terrestrial storm um of a sort of a
hurricane style but much less than that
um that was um that was actually keeping
a lot of boats from getting down there
we heard that a lot of people were stuck
in the keys couldn't get down there high
winds rain and it could be that these
birds do something y uh in such
circumstances and that whatever it is uh
about them that allows them to detect
when they're supposed to go spread out
again and go back to where they were so
that's a possibility too you know we
certainly weren't seeing huge numbers in
fact we didn't see any carcasses which
could mean nothing you might imagine
that you know nothing no carcasses no
carcasses so it could be that those
things are so quickly absorbed by the
Sea and whatever scavengers there are um
that you wouldn't encounter them but we
didn't see them um so you know it's
possible those birds are fine and
they're somewhere it's possible those
birds aren't fine and that this means
something
um
may maybe this doesn't fit with with
where you're going but um another thing
well one thing you've already mentioned
but two other organisms um that we saw a
lot of and uh were the N sharks which
are always fairly common in the places
that we have been there specifically on
a key called Compass key where um the
the fish entrails are all poured in in
the same place basically to encourage
the ner sharks to hang out they're
effectively tame uh it's a tourist
attraction for for people from um more
populated parts of the Bahamas um but
then we also saw I think and I haven't
been keeping track before but more Rays
we saw at least two species of rays uh
and uh we saw several of them and I
wonder if like jellies if um the the
kriis the shark skates and rays which
are all of a monoptic group they're all
closely related to one another and more
closely related to each other than any
are to any other species out there uh
might be particularly robust to um it
would probably be um pathogen at least
of the four uh and maybe to a massive
meaningful decline whatever cause that
would be uh than uh than smaller bodied
bony fishes um or um or to some of the
other inverts well I don't know you you
I haven't talked about this I don't I
think I saw fewer arays this time oh I
saw either four there were a place where
I might have seen four but it might have
been actually two that I saw twice um so
I either saw four or six I saw many
fewer Turtles mhm um I saw one uh
actually I saw one thing that must have
been a turtle that popped its head up uh
on our first day and then I saw another
turtle a very small one well so I mean
just in terms of what we're doing here
right this is um entirely anecdote we
wen't we're not we're not pretending
that we have data um but we have been to
the same spot three um three times
within 20 months of one another 22
months of one another and interesting
that you bring up Turtles I actually saw
a lot of turtles too but again I was in
this I was I was spending a lot of time
in this interior Lagoon uh where it is
so flat and the water is so shallow even
at Deep tide that there are no boats
going through there I I was having um to
walk my paddle board the even the fin on
the paddle board was too deep uh in some
places um at at low tide to get into
some of to to get into these lagoons and
it was there that I was seeing the Rays
I saw manta rays and I think sting rays
although I'm not 100% sure they were
sting rays Toby our younger son said
that um he he was pretty sure that one
of them um had had the had the sting uh
sort of visible on its end and many
turtles and so this of course is
consistent with what we know to be true
of of uh the risks of boat traffic to
manties for instance right uh that you
may find more of these organisms
specifically in the areas uh that we
don't frequent as much at least that we
don't frequent with our uh mechanized
Vehicles yeah although
that I don't see
how
the boat tra I see why it would account
for a higher density uh where the boats
can't go than out but it doesn't account
for a difference between this year and
any other
um but in any case so I wanted to just
do a couple comparisons first off the
story of species decline is one that I
think everybody who pays attention to
Nature is alarmed at we all have the
places that we used to go you know
especially the places we grew up and
knew well that have um seen spectacular
declines in things that seemed like they
would uh be there forever um there are
some cases that go in the other
direction um so for example you want to
show uh the
eagle
so I sent you an eagle you didn't get it
an eagle bald
eagle okay uh you want to show the
otter in any case we can talk about
these things and if Zach has them then
he'll show them but are these videos or
photographs photographs
um the the fact is when I was a kid I
don't think I ever saw a bald eagle I
think it is the kind of thing I would
have remembered as a kid um but are they
in La no but we spent a lot of time in
the sieras but are they in the Eastern
Sierra yeah um because just we have to
control for you know both space and time
of course you know to back to your point
about there often being um analoges and
sometimes more than analoges between
space and time phenomena and at this
point in the Pacific
Northwest we have so many bald eagles we
see them all the time right and it is
still exciting when people come you know
for other people from other parts of the
states and other parts of the the world
to see a bald eagle and I it's an
amazing bird it's a glorious bird um but
it's not a rarity uh but I don't know
that they are in the Eastern here and I
don't think they're in La well but even
to your point about bald eagles here um
I'm not sure you and I agree about this
but I think I'm seeing a small fraction
of what I saw last year at this time the
number of encounters I'm having with
them is much lower it's still
comparatively common um but it used to
be many times a day and now I can go a
couple days and not see one um so anyway
this could be normal EB and flow we have
to leave open that possibility um
especially when you're new to a place uh
as uh one of our mentors famously
pointed out about the weather in Central
America um the first year you go it's
normal and every year after that it's
not um so it can be that you just take
whatever your first uh your first year
somewhere is and you think that that's
Baseline and then things fluctuate and
you think it's all out of whack um but
what I would say
is I between the time uh I spent with uh
my parents in the
Sierra trip I did with my grandfather
driving across the country never seeing
a bald eagle is a pretty it does
indicate that they aren't in the places
um or they weren't in the places that
they are now and they've come you know
in this case there is lots of evidence
that they've come back spectacularly and
we see it um same thing with uh sea
otters which were hunted because of the
this is an animal that has
the thickest fur of any mammal it is so
thick that the water literally does not
touch their skin which is why they get
away with being in such cold Waters um
and how do they get away with being so
darn cute that's another matter entirely
um but in any case sea otters were
hunted to near Extinction they uh have
seen some trouble in recent years but
nonetheless it is the kind of uh thing
that is now relatively frequently cited
from Monterey North into Alaska they're
all over the place um and this is a
picture you took in Alaska or is this
here that's Alaska um yeah for whatever
reason in the Sailor sea and in the
Puget Sound um there are almost no sea
OTS what we have are river OTS um which
is something I would love to understand
why River ERS are comparatively yeah
they're in they're in the salt um uh but
they live on land whereas sea otter
never come on land um so anyway
something interesting is going on there
but salty River
dogs that they are um so sea otters are
a success uh story in terms of uh a
bounce back bald
eagles elephant seals were also down
below a 100 individuals um and they're
now uh and was that both northern and
southern or just the Northerns I believe
so it's definitely the Northerns I'm not
sure I don't know as much about the
Southerns Condors condor were actually
Condors went extinct in the wild in 1987
the year you and I graduated high school
um and they are now back we're talking
American Condors right uh California
Condors California that's right
California Condors California Condors
are now back and uh reproducing in the
wild with populations large enough that
we've actually seen wild individuals so
these are all stories of great success
but they have something in common which
is that they were
they had massive human efforts at
restoring them in the wild which oh
wolves also um which is very difficult
to do in the case of all the creatures
on the list we just uh put together
because these are all creatures in which
how to be an otter or an eagle uh or a a
u elephant
seal um or a condor is a lot of software
right the parents teach The Offspring
how to do the job and to the extent that
they've gone extinct in the wild nobody
knows how to do the job so humans have
um had to work very hard to reintroduce
animals that were not only
physiologically capable of doing the job
but also behaviorally capable of doing
it which means you can't just raise them
in a zoo- like environment and then
expect them to fend for themselves when
they get out into the wild but anyway
these are the acceptions not the rule
the decrease in uh the density of
species which we are all experiencing
and
otally um is a uh a troubling phenomenon
and it's also someplace that uh we often
you and I often trip over arguments that
are uh leveled by conservatives about
the fact that um environmental concerns
are overblown and in one way
environmental concerns May well be
overblown in some regards you and I have
talked about the uh problem of um models
being used to um augment arguments over
climate change and those models uh at
best are a mechanism for generating
hypothesis but they're being used to
test hypotheses which is um especially
in a political environment where you
can't possibly publish that you've uh
run a model on climate change and it
turns out it's much less of a big deal
than we thought or no big deal at all um
and they um in inherently reliant on the
assumptions built into them that is that
is the nature of models and uh the fact
that you see different results coming
out of different models is both exactly
what you would expect um but it also
means that when you see authors um
saying okay we we we just threw all
these models at um this data set and
these are the ones we're going to share
the results uh from with you uh you
should right away uh know to know to
wonder okay but what are the ones that
you didn't show us and what did they say
and why did you choose to show us the
ones um that H somehow actually fit your
preconceptions about what you would find
um that is it's kind the worst kind of
data mining really yeah it's going to
it's it's uh it's like active
overfitting where you're going to um
pick the models that spit out the right
answers and the problem with models is
that if you're free to put as many
parameters in as you want you can get
them to look like they match evidence
but it's really it's spous y um so
anyway there's a lot of skepticism and
uh quite justifiable skepticism in
conservative circles about uh climate
change being used as an excuse
for uh authoritarian changes in policy
for uh economic games being played on
people and PE and folks are rightly sick
of this but but they have uh largely
conflated um climate change with
environmental risk environmental
Devastation uh with you know coloring
all who would be concerned about the
environment or who would call themselves
an environmentalist as as I do as I
think you do uh as these harbingers of
Doom uh that are using flawed models uh
to build policy uh that forces us to you
know stop eating meat for instance right
uh to scold each other for driving too
far or whatever um so let me uh just say
we are we are therefore stuck first of
all we've got an academic environment
that's insane um that can't be trusted
to evaluate um anything because frankly
there's so much pressure inside of that
environment to reach conclusions that
have um been blessed by the proper
religious authorities that um that it's
not trustworthy but that means that in
terms of figuring out how healthy the
world is and what the effect of what
we're doing on the world is we are stuck
with far too much anecdote and the
problem is that anecdote really is
fraught with hazards and so um you want
to put up the picture of that
turn so I want to which one is the
zoomed out uh you start with the zoomed
out one so I want to return to uh this
photo about which I am proud because I
set out to take exactly this photo and
it took a few hours of work to figure
out how to get the bird and the ice to
both register in a way that made sense
but and then nature uh threw me a bone
in uh this animal doing something uh
that added to the photo I was trying to
take which is this is um a small fish is
in the beak of this Arctic turn um and
you can see the fish's eye so anyway
nature helped me out on this one but
point is we saw this is a this is an
animal i' wanted to see my whole life an
Arctic turn the reason I wanted to see
an Arctic turn is that Arctic turns do
something absolutely extraordinary which
is they migrate from pole to pole which
is something that is not typical we have
tremendous number of animals that
migrate from the tropics towards the
poles right that basically opt out of
winter by uh going south into warmer
climbs and then they uh profit from the
productivity and the reduction in
competition by flying uh North or South
into the temperate zones and Arctic
zones um when it's comparatively warm
but an animal that migrates from one
pole to the other is really interesting
and so anyway I'd always wanted to see
them and never have um they're hard to
see um in this case we saw them in
abundance but we saw them in abundance
because we happen to catch the migration
as it passed through Southeast Alaska
and so in early May right now if you
hadn't known what an Arctic turn was or
hadn't known that was an Arctic turn you
could very well have had the sense of oh
uh these birds were so common and then
you could return the next year two weeks
off think you were there in the same
season and not see a one and think what
the hell happened did the population
crash and the answer is no it didn't
crash you just missed the exact moment
that it passed through this exact
location and happen to seem like it was
at very high density um when in fact you
know there just aren't that many so
anyway you have to be careful with
anecdote because you run into patterns
you don't know and those patterns can
create structure where the animal is not
distributed in a way that's perfectly
even and then as you pass through the EB
and flow across space of where this
animal is you think you're seeing
changes in the population but you're
really just seeing um movement or
something else
um so we are stuck go ahead well
actually I wanted to go back to you
provided a list um sort of off the top
of your head but about the the four
reasons that you identified uh that we
might not be seeing organisms where we
expected to uh and you said migration
pathogen local patchiness and massive
meaningful decline MH um and I guess I
think um that's not a list of
Alternatives quite uh
because uh local patchiness could be due
to pathogen right um although I think
the local patchiness that's more
interesting is actually species a is
reliant on species B and species B is um
using the turo of the of the soil to
thrive there and not there and so you
will find species a um you know being in
in in literally in soil patches uh that
has nothing to do necessarily with
pathogens um but sometimes local
patchiness will be actually um you know
in the case of gosh this krid fungus uh
that was uh finally identified after uh
many years of uh herbologists that is
those who study uh amphibians and
reptiles seeing all these declines in
frogs across a lot of the tropics it
turns out that one of the major things
one of the major uh explanations for
that was this krid fungus that was
largely being brought in by oh my God
herpetologists right and that's you know
that wasn't the major thing but that was
in some cases in some populations of the
most charismatic most well studied
species of frogs oh and now these are
disappearing it's like oh it was the
people who came in to study them um you
know how how awful is that so um the
local patchiness um of of some species
of frogs in that case was due in fact to
a pathogen that was coming in on I don't
know the boots or the clothes of of
people who were who were going to study
them um massive meaningful decline
obviously could precisely be due to
pathogen um but the thing that may be um
most obscure to people who are listening
uh is with regard to the potential
relationship between year numbers one
and two migration and pathogen where you
know why it's we we could spend hours
talking separately about why migrate
like what what is migration about why do
some organisms migrate and some don't um
sometimes very closely organisms some
stay resident some some don't in fact
within species um in some cases it tends
to be short distance migrants where some
species especially bats actually like in
the Pacific Northwest some species
migrate short distances and some just
stay put um hummingbirds too right there
a lot of altitudinal migration Andes for
example um but then um but you can have
long-distance migrants uh where the
places that they migrate to uh are are
quite different even within closely
related species and and one of the
reasons that has been proposed for many
of the Shorebirds for instance to
migrate
into uh Northern wintering grounds uh
where they you know they they get there
and um they build nests and they attract
mates if they're not monogamous if they
haven't been traveling with their mates
and uh and you know they build nests
they have kids right away they have eggs
and then they're there in these densely
populated colonies where they brewed
their eggs and then they raised their
young uh until they're young or ven
until they're they're they're old enough
to fly and make the trip and then
they're out of there and they abandon um
the the breeding grounds and and head
back south and you it's really easy to
imagine this is just due to climate
right like how how are how are all these
Birds going to have enough to eat and
stay warm enough uh and uh in a in San
Alaskan winter uh and of course the
colder it is the more they will need to
eat so uh the the food being limiting is
even more of an issue for them if
they're in a cold climate but turns out
that at the point that they're leaving
those breeding grounds those breeding
grounds are just filled with
ectoparasites and uh you know we tend to
use the word pathogen for endoparasites
rather than ectoparasites but it's it's
parasites all the same and uh how do you
deal with uh your bed being full of bed
bugs um your lice or fleas or whatever
it is well you could move and people
don't tend to want to do that you know
sometimes they have to burn all their
bedding or whatever but you can just
move be like you know what given your
lifespan and my lifespan I'm leaving for
the season I'll be back in eight months
and by then you'll all be dead and I
will have fresh new fresh new land to to
colonize and um by the end of next
breeding season here we are again uh you
have once again accumulated and uh we're
going to leave again well um your point
is well taken the four uh explanations
potential explanations are not mutually
exclusive in this case and in the case
that you're talking about you have the
same puzzle which is the ectoparasites
are a reason to leave a rookery and the
climate is another and there's nothing
that says they aren't both driving
forces and teasing out to what extent
one contributes uh versus the other is
is interesting um in the case of the
four potential reasons to see uh a
massive decrease in the number of
individuals of a particular species um
these things interact in various ways um
as a population crashes I mean so the we
could I mean we also didn't like
competition is obviously another one and
specifically where where we're talking
about you know human competition
potentially like for conks like we're
seeing the opposite but uh if we had
seen the conks disappear to nothing it
would have been very easy to assume they
got overh harvested maybe that wasn't
what happened in fact that isn't what
happened at all because we're seeing
more of them yeah um but it's very easy
to jump to the thing that's dominant on
your mind oh they migrate because it
gets cold oh they're gone because we eat
them um oh all the megaphon in North
America disappeared because we hunted
them out well maybe and maybe and maybe
and you know maybe not in all of those
cases is that the driving reason for why
those things disappeared yeah I mean the
the the key point is that there will
always I think this is logically right
there will always be a driving reason
and there may be other contributing
factors the idea that two reasons are
exactly um equal in terms of importance
is like there being two limiting factors
like no there's always one that's a
little bit more than the other or a lot
more um but the uh the question of a
spectacular decline so you point out
spectacular decline could be the result
of over harvesting that's not going to
be the case in gulls nobody eats them or
no yeah uh no humans eat them um it
could be the result of toxic exposures
which is what I really worry most about
that the number of Novel compounds that
we're putting into the world and the
industri scale on which we are doing it
um creates massive microplastics and
just the runoff from the the you know
just the Blackwater tanks and the boats
and the and not the stuff from the tanks
maybe but the treatment of the stuff
from the tanks stuff in the tanks is
unlikely um right because you know the
the ocean absorbs a lot of that true um
but the things people used to treat it
to keep their boats from stinking um
potentially uh could have that
consequence then there's of course the
question of pesticides and fertilizers
and all of these other other things and
you know as a population decreases and
again we haven't established that the
goal population decreased it could have
been somewhere else when we were there
and they could have been hunkered down
from the recent storm yeah or it could
be that past experiences they had
concentrated where we were for some
reason that we weren't aware of and so
that they tend to be thinner on the
ground you know it could go either way
um but if a population were to crash for
some reason for example uh the result of
um pollution or a pathogen then of
course there's a point at which the
population is so small that you have
inbreeding depression which is to say
that the individuals are going to be
less capable of for example um uh
dealing with uh toxins you know yep and
just and and then stochastic events have
a greater chance of actually wiping you
out yeah or uh resisting pathogens a
less diverse population is going to be
um as the pathogen leaps from one person
or one individual to the next it's going
to have an easier time because it's
already figured out the formula and
everybody's genetically more similar
than they might otherwise be hey
diversity is our strength it should be
actually diversity is our immunological
strength right um that said um I think
we've talked about this on Dark Horse
before um in breeding is a topic that is
widely misunderstood because the danger
to a newly inbreeding
population is so obvious that people
assume that inbreeding simply has this
consequence but the
reason uh I won't get too deep in the
weeds here but the reason that
inbreeding is a hazard is because
individuals carry what are called
delarius recessive genes in significant
numbers these are genes that you don't
suffer from because you only have one
copy um so it's estimated that humans
have something like each of us on
average carry something like eight genes
that if we had two copies of them would
be fatal or nearly so because we have
one copy we never we never aware of them
and as long as you mate with somebody
who's sufficent sufficiently uh
Divergent from you you're very unlikely
to bring two copies of the same uh
delarius recessive gene together that's
why you're not supposed to marry closer
than first cousin is where it's
traditionally uh been but in any case um
the so as a population declines and
individuals are forced to choose among a
smaller pool of mates the likelihood
that they mate with somebody who's
closely related to them goes up and you
see the deformity and uh feebleness of
individuals but what that does is it
also exposes those delarius recessives
to selection which selects them out and
so um so if the population survives
right so in the case of then it's likely
to be more robust afterwards possibly is
the argument here well at the very least
those genes are um those particular U
relatively simple filtered to an extent
so you know you expect when you hear sea
otters are down to a population of less
than 100 or elephant seals or cond or
cheetahs or any of cheetah it's still
much higher than that but nonetheless
there's always a concern about
inbreeding but there's also the okay
well if they survive the inbreeding um
then you're dealing with a creature
that's better at surviving inbreeding
right it's been favored for it
so anyway it's a it's not exactly a
double-edged sword it's a hidden um a
hidden reason to be less concerned about
that particular threat um
but anyway I don't know where any any of
this leaves us other than um there's a
general pattern of decline of species
that those of us who pay attention to
these things are noticing everywhere
there are cases in which things go the
other direction like uh Jellyfish and
con there are lots of reasons to see um
variation that have nothing to do with
overall decline so you have to be very
careful with anecdote um but um all of
these things you know the the punchline
of the story is that zero is an
absorbing boundary a population of zero
does not rebound right a population that
the deer populations up here that were
hit literally decreased by something
like 90% mhm came on those same Islands
now you'd never know that there was a
problem with the deer they bounced back
to it was observable to you know us as
biologists who'd spent time up here
before we moved up here the last time
that we visited before we lived here we
noticed and we started asking people and
say oh yeah yeah this this happened
they're they're practically gone and
apparently it had been um like a horror
show like they' been lying dead it CL
multiple dead animals in yard and stuff
like this um but anyway they bounced
back you'd never know um that it had
happened if you if you came here now um
so anyway many things are possible but
the really important thing is that you
don't hit zero right anytime you hit
zero on one of these things there's no
fixing it right it's just done um so I
don't know how we have that
discussion I'm sympathetic with those
who are fed up with the academy telling
them uh what freedoms there to give up
because of some um
change in the world that may or may not
be uh exaggerated or even real um on the
other hand at some point you got to uh
start paying attention probably
everybody who watches this podcast if
they think back to places that they used
to know very well and have gone back to
recently will be able to detect some of
these things um and uh and the pattern
is uh it's not only frightening but it's
it's tragic yeah I think we have an
obligation to deliver the Next
Generation a world that is no less than
the one we inherited right it's not very
you can't go very many generations in a
road degrading the world before you
leave a place that is just severely
broken
indeed
um well that seems that seems like a
good conversation to have had and maybe
that's sufficient but um maybe let me
just say a few things about these
curly-haired dogs these woolly dogs of
the Pacific North Northwest all right um
that are
extinct but um oh you can you can show
my screen here Zack and I'll just say a
little bit about them um some research
has has recently been published so this
is the science news uh article version
of it and then I'll sh I'll share a
little bit from the actual um
peer-reviewed publication um but the
title here is curly-haired woolly dogs
of the Pacific Northwest were no myth
long history of unique dogs recovered by
weaving together data from DNA and Coast
Salish oral Traditions so the like the
reason I wanted to talk about this it's
so beautiful when uh you know we have
with with the wokies going on now we
have a lot of people claiming uh that
Western science is no better than other
kinds of Science and you know how dare
we come in uh with our hypotheses and
our predictions and our data and our
statistics and make claims that we know
more than the people who have oral
Traditions from generations to
generations and I would say that the
best scientists don't say I know more
than what you say you have seen But
Western science is the best tool that we
have to understand what is true and how
remarkable when we can use tools both
from modern science Western science and
from oral tradition and from myth and
find that the answers that we come up
with are in fact consistent with one
another and so this article which if you
would show the screen here Zach um this
is just the science news article
um this is a a reconstruction of uh of
of the dog from the Coast Salish uh with
this is a I guess they haven't shown it
here um this there was there was one
individual left in the 19th century um
and so basically modern genetic
techniques have pulled uh fur from this
this one dog named mutton uh from the
19th century and then talk to Elders um
Elders who have stories from their
grandparents talking about these dogs
and uh so just uh first couple
paragraphs of this piece here growing up
in chilak Canada in the 1950s and 60s
stolo Nation I have no idea how to
pronounce the the gladle stop or
whatever it is there uh Grand Chief
Steven Point listen to his Elders tells
stories of fluffy white dogs whose fur
was once woven into blankets for the
Tripes tribes hereditary leaders by then
it had been nearly a century since any
stolo or other Coast Salish people had
seen a so-called woolly dog alive or
dead some Western Scholars thought they
were myths or exaggerations the dogs
were all gone Point says and we had just
that stories nobody knew what happened
and of course it is true that throughout
much of the 20th century uh Western
science came in sort of trumpets blaring
and presumed that we already had the
answers we knew it was what and people
who had already lived places were
technologically inferior and therefore
perhaps morally inferior as well and
therefore we couldn't trust what they
said uh this is by and large not what is
going on in Western science anymore but
it was the story of Western science and
sort of conquest of of local peoples for
a long time and so it's not that
surprising that um having no dogs in
front of them and myths about dogs uh
for the most part Western science said
yeah whatever I'm sure you had dogs but
they were probably from Japan or
something like there are lots of dogs
around uh well new This research um so
you can show this again this is um sorry
this is published in science I haven't
read this can I uh leap to put the
question on the table that undoubtedly
this is going to answer okay I don't I
don't know if I will be able to answer
it but go ahead well
um one of two things has to be true
either these dogs came in with the
people into the Americas or these dogs
are the result of a separate
domestication event I would bet they
came in with the people but that's
interesting if they did we we think now
based on um the combination of molecular
evidence from the DNA analysis of this
one dog mutton from uh the 1800s who
whose coat was partially
preserved uh in combination with the
stories of exactly how the elders preser
like dealt with these dogs they were
beloved but they were also um prohibited
from interbreeding with other dogs
because they were being bred for their
coats that had a very rich undercoat
plus this long spiral Overcoat which was
particularly weavable and then they were
woven with some other um other hairs
like goat sometimes and they were
particularly conducive to making warm
long- live blankets and so the women of
many of the coastal Salish people
apparently were in particular uh charge
of the dogs they were understood to be
um you know sort of in the life is all
of a thing uh ethos um particularly
closely related to the dogs and actually
had them uh isolated on some particular
their islands where they were uh kept
from interbreeding with other other dogs
and also yes it seems that they came
over 12 15,000 years ago from Asia from
domestic dog stock in Asia um with with
the people with the people so let me
just um so the influence of people um I
don't know if this is exactly appropo
what we were just talking about but um
the influence of people on The Woolly
dog genome woolly dogs were treated as
beloved extended family memb
according to Deborah quason Sparrow and
mus Master Weaver her grandfather Ed
Sparrow who lived from 1898 to 1998 told
her that quote every village had woolly
dogs that they were like gold because
they were mixed with the mountain goat
and then Rove and spun the the fur was
dogs also comprised a form of wealth and
status for Coast Salish women who
carefully manage the dogs to maintain
their woolly coats isolating them on
Islands or in pens to strictly manage
their breeding island names often
reflect their connection with dogs such
as I'm not going to try saying it in
planket or whatever language this is
little dog Village on Cameron Island in
Nimo something territory British um
British Columbia the prevention of
interbreeding wool dogs with hunting or
Village dogs was critical for
maintaining their distinct hair
characteristics soft guard hairs with an
unusually long crumpy undercoat which
was highly spinnable and could be made
into warm blanket
yarn these management practices likely
contributed to mutton's PCD ancestry
long after the onset of settler
colonialism so I think part of why
Western scientists disbelieved this like
yeah but there had been European dogs
Europeans had been there for hundreds of
years already um or at least a couple a
hundred or two and surely you know you
people right would not have been able to
maintain their integrity as an isolated
population for so long but yep they did
and so the stories being told by the co-
Salish uh turn out to be true and this
really was a distinct breed um that is
now gone unfortunately so I would uh
guess here um that the isolation of
these individuals the fact that it would
have been a small highly prized
population that was being prized for its
um Purity Made Them vulnerable and that
in fact I wonder if there is not a
mirror of the story of smallpox
spreading in the new world if there was
not you know uh
a analogous story for actually the
same almost the same reasons the reason
that pathogens um wiped out the new
world populations had to do with various
factors people should read Guns Germs
and Steel if they're curious um about
this but um the difference
in um domesticable animals in the New
World versus primarily Asia where most
of our domesticated animals came from
gave the old world population exposure
to pathogens so they had already
equilibrated and those pathogens were
highly virulent to the new world
population which had only um camelids
vuna I think yep um as or alpaca and The
Descendant Funia I think that's how it
goes yeah whatever the Chad was that
they domesticated that was the only New
World large uh domesticate um that they
had and so the exposure to pathogens was
much less so I wonder if the dogs uh
from Europe which would have made
contact at the same time or close to it
uh had resistance to disease that
especially an isolated population of New
World dogs wouldn't have had yeah so the
story laid out here I wasn't going to go
here and I didn't spend a lot of time
here with this paper because
unfortunately it sort of it's pitched in
the the modern language of um let's
blame the newcomers it's always the
Newcomer's fault right in this case I it
was the Newcomer's fault um but I but
the tone is is so common now and so
often just barbarically wrong that it's
not worth usually spending time there
but um what they say is um by 1857 a
year before mutton's birth in STO
territory excuse me where mutton was
most likely acquired so mutton belonged
to a white guy uh is part of why we
still we have the remnants from it
because this this white guy acquired I
think um by reasonable means this dog
whom he loved and that he saved part of
mutton after he died and that's how we
come to have di in 1859 of course I
don't know but no it's in the abstract
was it yes I missed that okay so we're
in that kind of numerology territory now
but yeah okay
um uh where muton was most likely
acquired the settler population
consisted of only a few dozen permanent
settlers at Fort Langley the following
year more than 33,000 miners arrived at
present day BC during the 1858 Frasier
River Gold Rush this large scale
migration set off conflicts between
minors colonial governments and
Indigenous peoples indigenous
populations declined by an estimated 2/3
between 1830 and 1882 small poox
epidemics epidemics almost one every
generation from the 1700s to 1862 are
estimated to have killed more than 90%
of indigenous people in some Villages
across BC along with Stud depopulation
due to other introduced diseases such as
mumps tuberculosis and influenza one
more thing though um culturally so
that's like again that's sort of the
easy one it's the it's the germs part of
Guns Germs and Steel pathogens are real
and certainly to a naive in terms of
never before been exposed population
they're going to have particularly High
efficacy which isn't good for the
pathogen
either um but there's also a cultural
effect here survival of woolly dogs
depended upon the survival of their
caretakers because because of what we've
already talked about in addition to
disease expanding colonialism increased
cultural upheaval displacement of
indigenous peoples and a diminished
capacity to manage the breed policies
targeted indigenous governance and
inherent rights resulting in the
deliberate disenfranchisement and
criminalization of indigenous cultural
practices so um and you know it goes on
but that suggests that maybe maybe
there's some remnants of The Woolly dog
genome left in some dogs yeah like the
Andals in modern humans precisely yep
precisely MH that'd be cool yeah that's
a nice looking dog it's a really nice
looking dog yeah and in fact so um the
science news article had a had a partial
version of this but um so here we have
the moral is if you want to show this oh
that didn't help wow yeah um maybe I can
do it this way um okay so uh this is
from figure one of this paper um and you
have the biggest dog these are all
domesticates um but the the big Alaskan
Malamute sad husky Husky's bigger than
this uh coish willly dog um but not by a
ton and this is the size is s similar
more similar to The Finnish spits and to
some degree um the so-called German
spits the American Eskimo dog but not
closely related H that you can you you
can make a similar dog out of not so
similar starting points well that that
has got to be the case given that they
all start at one point right yep all
right well that's cool yeah that is cool
um so maybe uh that's where we should
finish for this our last full live
stream of 2023
yes I I think that's you look at me like
you were surprised like what no that
that sounded like the beginning of a
compound sentence and I was interested
to see where it
went all right uh so we will come back
with a Q&A shortly and we will also come
back with a private Q&A on
locals on Sunday uh New Year's Eve at
11:00 a.m.
Pacific and oh we didn't talk about
emotional eavesdropping in rats maybe
next time next time yeah or um on snake
societ is being maintained by females
maybe next time all right yeah just
little teasers for 2024 snake societies
maintained by females and emotional
Eaves dropping in rats with trigger
warning for you some evidence that cats
know their names some evidence that cats
know their names that's about all you're
going to get no we could keep going here
now I think we'll save it for 2024 okay
yeah it's going to be a big year yeah
yes it's going to be a big year yeah boy
it going to be a big year cats know
their
names we'll see let's just see okay so
um please join us on on Rumble uh and on
locals lots of stuff uh that lots of
benefits to joining us on locals and um
at the store you have things like scop
until proven otherwise fizer the
breakthroughs never stop blueberries
because accidents happen and if you live
in one of those places where they are
thinking about bringing masks back you
can always get some Jake's micro
pizza so good and they now have it in
both gluten-free and dairyfree options
for those of you who have
sensitivities and um because it's so
small no one knows when you're done
eating and that means you can keep the
mask down no you just keep eating the
micro Pizza no one knows when you're
done and you can just keep the mask down
okay um I did I posted this week on
Natural Selections a year in review uh
uh so uh check out natural selections.
substack do.com for some highlights from
uh the writing that I did there this
this
year um what else I feel like there's a
lot else we we encourage uh you again to
join us at locals and we really
appreciate your support at this um the
end of the third full year that we've
been doing this uh we are as always very
grateful to you our audience and until
we see you next time be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
be well
[Music]
everyone